Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
[inaudible]
checking in on you.
Just checking in on you.
How are you?
How's your week going?
Oh,
don't worry.
It's almost over.
It starts day,
right?
Don't you get paid on Thursday?
Back in the day you did.
He get dead fucking check,
right.
They'll piece of paper with the numbers on it.
Then you go down to the bank,
you fucking,
you right on the back.
You stick it in the machine and then the numbers say you got this number right.
It's just a bunch of numbers.
It's all it is.
It's all,
it comes down to,
um,
I'm actually,
I'm in a great mood.
I got a great night's sleep last night.
Uh,
went out and visited some friends of mine.
It drove home about 80 miles an hour,
85,
sometimes 90.
Oh,
I was cruising.
And even when,
you know,
they fixed the highways at night,
which totally makes sense.
You can't do it during the day,
but she always get mad at night.
You like,
Geez,
he's fucking cry.
Even if there isn't traffic,
they got an authentic traffic jam and you get all fucking mad.
Cause if fixing a highway it fuck at one 30 in the morning when you should be in
bed.
Right?
When the fuck else are they going to do it?
That's why I just kept telling myself as I was getting mad,
you know,
I'd be cruising along this fucking great.
This is great.
Looking at it is flying down the fucking highway.
90 fucking miles an hour.
You should be able to do this all the time.
24 seven get the population down where whenever I fucking want I can jump on the
highway happy.
Then five minutes right over right.
And then all of a sudden you come over the hill and you see that Arrow and then
you see the brake lights and eat us guy.
Ah Yeah,
fucking assholes.
You know.
Hey ACDC crankin cause I'm a middle aged,
not even middle aged.
I'm 47 times two is fucking 94.
Who's kidding?
Who you guys think all red face is going to make 95?
Um,
I'm an old fuck.
I'm an old white guy who likes Facebook and I'm listening to ACDC and I'm
rocking out
in my hybrid.
Oh yeah,
that's what I'm doing.
I'm doing everything to wearing those Mervyn's shoes where those fucking awful
shoes that people a little bit older than me were.
They wear them with no socks and dead jeans.
Those slip on fucking shoes that I think we're cool for like two weeks in like
1993 there.
Mervin's right?
Melvin's
what's a melon?
I'm Melvin.
Somebody fucking gives you a Wedgie.
Um,
who the fuck ever thought to do that?
You realize how funny that is?
Like I said,
well,
nobody thought to do it until it was pants and then once it was pants.
So he's just like,
God dammit.
He sees a riding up on me and then it just wrote up on the wrong sadistic guy's
ass.
And he's like,
you know what?
What if I did that a lot quicker to somebody else?
A lot harder on purpose.
Premeditated riding up with Jason when he heard the scream of uncomfortableness.
It warmed,
it's hard.
And then some others sadistic,
fuck it.
Or maybe just some fucking a,
you're like joke faith's except like a fucking bully.
Like thief.
One of bullies do that.
Like they see a bully bullying somebody else.
It'd be like,
you know,
I'm to,
I,
you know,
I'm going to do something like that.
We do my version of that.
Then the bully calls him out on Twitter.
Then there's a big dust up,
right.
Then they got to go on a bully podcast and clear the name.
Yeah.
Anyways,
um,
who knows,
who knows in this day and age of non controversies becoming controversies,
who knows what could happen.
Um,
yeah,
I'm in a great mood.
I got home one 30 in the morning,
I put on the Celtics.
I still haven't watched the Bruins beating the Canadians.
I know they'd beat to Canadians.
I'm fucking trying to do the basketball and hockey thing.
And um,
so I'm behind like two games with the Bruins and I know they got Vancouver
tonight and I just checked the standings.
What the fuck happened at the Canadians
by Boston?
Bruin heart was in my fucking throat when they started off at nine.
And Oh my God,
no,
they're going to end the drought this year.
They're going to end the drought and then what am I going to say?
I got nothing.
I already have.
The only thing I can say is how long it's been since they won their last one.
Cause other than that,
they can go like,
yeah,
well we got like 52 of them.
It's like,
yeah,
but you know,
the first 12,
you were beaten like,
you know,
the fucking Montreal Marauders,
the Quebec Con Keester doors,
you know,
you won best fucking,
uh,
best five out of nine,
whatever the fucking series was when you played on a pond.
Do you realize how fucked up it is in the Stanley Cup?
Was the size of a shot glass,
you know,
hurry up and finish this game so we can have world war one.
Um,
that's really w I mean,
I don't give a fuck that they count those things.
I just like teasing him about it.
Um,
even at just count the ones from the modern era,
we're never going to catch him.
I realized that as a fan.
Um,
what was I gonna say?
The,
uh,
I still for the life of me do not understand as we are now at super bowl 50,
why NFL championships do not count it.
Nobody has ever been able to give me a logical explanation to that.
All right.
Is it because the two leaks combined rather than the NFL absorbed the AFL?
You know,
the way the NBA absorbed,
you know,
like four or five Aba teams.
Is that what it is?
But for the life of me,
it's like those championships were one,
they will wonder in those years,
like take like the eagles see eagles like,
oh,
they never want to fucking,
you know,
a Superbowl gives a fuck.
I mean,
it's sucks.
it's been a long fucking time,
but they did win a championship in 1960.
Okay.
And the way,
the way the NFL acts like that was caveman days.
Like Mickey Mantle was in the prime of his career.
Baseball still drops to their knees,
you know,
in an honor of that guy.
Okay.
And forget about fucking Babe Ruth,
you know.
Okay.
Who Fuck,
he's,
who's fucking Rehab was eating hot dogs and drink beer and catching up to the
fucking the team on the train by,
by jumping in a biplane.
If he wasn't too fucking fat with weight and balance.
Right.
They could find a scarf long enough to,
Rachael Brown has giant fucking elephant neck.
Right.
Why don't they count us
that mood?
Jim Brown's title doesn't count.
What was it,
64 65 the last time.
The browns warning slash.
Ravens.
Um,
I dunno.
I didn't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I thought it was in a good mood.
I'm already going country anyways.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened to the Canadians.
Like as of today,
they are one point.
They,
you know,
the season ended today,
they wouldn't make the playoffs.
So I'm going to go out on a limb and say that Canadians team,
I'll tell you those,
those Montreal Canadians,
they're very streaky.
Okay.
I'll tell you right now,
if they're not looking unbeatable,
they are looking a unwinnable I,
what are the fucking say?
Anyways,
let me plow ahead here.
So,
um,
I got to watch that game at some point,
but I'm,
uh,
I'm getting ready to do the,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit,
the wonderful Patrice O'Neil,
the best comic I have a fucking saw.
Um,
okay.
You know,
for my generation it's just,
it,
it's just a fact.
He's the best and a wonderful positive night of a,
of hilarity supporting the people that uh,
Patrice was taken care of.
All his,
his,
his loved ones.
Uh,
that is Tuesday.
And uh,
from what I hear it,
it's all sold out,
but we will be releasing at the last second a few tickets,
um,
here or there,
which I guess is what they do at all conscious people.
We say that going like,
you know,
oh I wanted to see fucking whatever,
whatever band,
you know,
and a dude you just like an hour before you just walk up and they release
tickets.
That's like a sub sick fucking level of being able to get tickets,
you know,
cause I'd be the Asshole,
I just go to fucking stubhub.
Speaking of which,
I wanted to go see Bob Newhart.
Bob Newhart is doing a show out in the desert at some casino.
Right.
When I say out in the desert,
I mean the 10 east to like Luquita right.
He's out there cause uh,
you know that's a,
that's a,
I think that's his generation.
That's where they fucking,
that's where they retired.
You know that place was like,
that place was like a what Brooklyn is now.
Oh,
like silver lake out here.
Like where all the hipsters are.
That's what that was to his generation,
I think way back in the day.
And those stayed out there and they retired that.
So I fucking go on.
I go on the inner web.
There is Richard Rawlings says on gas monkey.
I go on the interweb and he and I tried to get tickets,
sold the fuck out.
Okay.
I was so upset that I couldn't get a fucking ticket.
But on the other level I'm like,
this guy is 83 years old and he's still selling out the big room in a casino.
You don't fucking awesome.
That is
credible,
you know,
ridiculous is that he's worked clean his whole career and I'm sitting here
cursing up a storm,
giving them compliments.
I'm going to figure out a way,
I'm going to get to that show.
It's so not January 29th.
I'm going to figure out a way to get in there.
I don't know what I gotta do,
you know,
maybe I'll fuck it.
Drive all the way out to desert and I'll stand around,
you know,
hoping that maybe a couple of audience members died.
The tickets got freed up.
Oh,
come on bill.
Let's,
let's,
let's not take it to a negative place this close to the AFC and NFC championship
games.
How could you do that?
You know,
speaking of dying,
by the way,
speaking of death,
um,
you know,
I went on the Internet today and I was looking up,
uh
Oh,
where the fuck is it?
here it is.
Here it is installed later.
Get out of here.
Beat it.
Trying an hour.
Try it tonight.
Jesus.
How can you be more fucking needy?
All right.
Where is it?
New York City.
Okay.
Discusses World's largest tax funded mass grave might be turned into a park.
And I lived in New York.
What bad dad dead starts spreading the news.
I'm wearing sweatpants,
I'm gunna go down to Tad's steaks,
Eddie some shit.
And I'll feel like I'm making it.
The air,
you know,
successful New Yorkers think just cause they're in Manhattan.
You know what I mean?
Everybody looks at themselves like they're the star,
you know?
No one sees themselves as background,
you know what I mean?
You're the ones waving up at the Beatles.
You're not in the Beatles.
You understand?
You're the one in the crowd screaming.
You know,
fainting is,
security takes you out.
As you look at it,
somebody's successful.
Right.
That's who you are.
Yeah.
Those people already on the subways.
They try to jam another person in there and the world needs you.
The world needs you.
Okay.
If I can go to white castle and a photo,
dope.
A cheeto those Burgers,
I'll be a fat fuck.
Yeah,
the Upper Dag,
I'm sorry.
All right.
World's largest tax funded mass graves.
So there's an island out there,
which I had no idea.
Uh,
I mean I knew of Ellis Island and then is the island that the statue of Liberty
is on.
Then I knew there was one that the navy owned or some shit,
but there's this other island out there dead.
Uh,
they just bury people that don't have any money or nobody knows who the fuck
they are.
It's called Hart Island or is it tourism?
Boston would say fucking island.
Let's go out to,
maybe we can find a fucking uncle
got in trouble with the bookie.
Um,
hard island,
New York.
Rosalie Grable looks down over rows of white pipes,
some broken or covered in mud sticking out of the dirt.
Each two marks the grave of 150 adults,
a dash homeless poor veterans and unclaimed individuals who couldn't afford
anything but a spot in what's widely to believe to be the world's largest tax
funded mass grave.
Okay.
You know,
tax funded mass grave,
not mass grave cause believe me,
I think,
isn't there one underneath the,
isn't there one underneath like Wall Street,
these massive curate a bunch of native Americans is some shit.
Then they just buried them all isn't not what they used to do back then.
All right.
That takes care of that.
Who wants to build a log cabin?
Right?
Lunatics.
Um,
so what of a Grable,
a 64 year old resident of the upper west,
upper west side,
once grass and wild flowers to hide the dirty white plastic.
She's come here to honor our mother who died in a hospital bed with no savings
to leave to her daughter.
She said,
I'm still getting used to the idea that my mommy wound still calls her mommy.
That's creepy.
Uh,
wound up in a potter's grave.
I know.
That's my mother.
I know that my mother was expecting something more true,
much more traditional.
I don't understand people who like when they die,
they want to have one of those above ground fucking like tubes.
You know,
like the,
it's like the above ground swimming pool of grave sites.
You know,
it's like,
how fucking special do you think you are?
Because you're dead.
They should just have mass graves that you'd have a giant pit.
You just fucking,
you know,
the family doesn't need to see it,
but yet is to fucking throw it in there though it in there and then use your
dissolve.
You become the next fossil fuel.
Right?
Think about all the fucking people that have lived in the world.
If we had in one giant fucking massive grave in each country and it used
whatever fucking you,
I don't know how the fuck he ended up turning into motor oil whenever Deli.
That's what happens.
I know if you jump off a building,
you explode like a water balloon because you're mostly water and I don't know if
you eat a lot of Italian food,
you know like I do.
You've got a lot of olive oil in you.
Who knows?
Maybe you like him,
help out somebody fucking lawn mower in the future.
That's what they should do.
Holy Shit that I just solved global warming.
Well maybe I solved the Middle East crisis.
Yeah.
And if elected,
okay,
I will begin burying all dead Americans are the same hall and a hundred years
from now we will use they'll fossil fuel that that is created to free ourselves
from the Saudi Arabia.
I am so sick of sea world leaders go to the UN and like we have a friend
of some sort of a friendship.
Um,
I don't know if there's something you could do,
but anyways,
I'll get,
became fascinated with that expression I was saying right.
Potter's grave.
So I looked it up and of course,
you know,
my research on the Internet,
on the Internet never goes past Wikipedia.
Never goes past it,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
all right.
A Potter's Field Comma poppers field or a common grave is a term for a place for
the burial of unknown or
indigent people or was that indigent?
All right,
so I clicked on indigent or indeed I don't,
isn't it astounding how fucking dumb I y'all ain't astounding about how stupid I
am.
It's the fact that you guys fucking listen to this.
I actually thought it was halfway smart until I started reading out loud.
Here.
I N D I,
g e n,
t
indigent.
Indigent.
You say tomato.
I say indigent.
Indigent.
I'm just going to stop saying it.
I just come this way.
I feel like every time I say it,
I'm like fucking a,
I'm like,
that guy.
I'm playing blackjack on.
Hit me,
hit me,
hit me over.
Over.
Your fucking Iq was just going down.
All right,
so I looked up
that word that I'm not gonna say anymore.
Oh God.
Is it possible to get embarrassed on a podcast that only you are doing?
You know it's possible.
I'm doing it.
All right.
Palm and I,
and what is it ends up coming up is poverty.
Poverty is a general scarcity dearth or the slate of one button,
but what the F,
how did this come to a,
after the industrial revolution,
mass production in factories made product production goods increasingly less
expensive and more accessible of more important is the modernization of the
agriculture's at fertilize.
It dented.
The poverty reduction is a major goal.
I'll give me a fee.
Is it really?
Is it really a major goal when the fucking CEO takes 80% of the profits?
Huh?
One of the guys who's fucking work in the line,
his daughter's already hooking is up in the CEO's office,
blowing them,
you know,
cause she can't go to fucking collar.
Then the circle is complete.
Oh,
that was a little poetry there.
All right.
The u s expression,
let me get back to the Potter's field.
Potter's field derives from the Bible.
Oh.
Gj Age.
Referring to a field used for the extraction of Potter's clay.
Such land used for agriculture could be used as a burial site.
So after they dug out all the clay,
they just threw people in there.
Well,
there you go.
That's a good use of space.
Okay.
All right.
The term comes to all,
let's,
let's read some Bible.
Oh my God.
I know.
I've done this.
Read some Bible,
Brits,
sweet from the Bible.
The term comes from Matthew 27 Semi-colon oh colon,
the three dash seven colon,
eight in the new testament of the Bible in which Jewish priest take.
Okay.
Just 30 pieces of silver returned by a remorseful Judas Colon.
Oh,
Jesus.
Be some antisemitic shit.
Okay.
And then this one says,
then Judas,
who portrayed him?
I think that's Jay Star.
He betrayed Jay star.
They're seeing that he was condemned,
repented himself,
brought back the 30 pieces of silvers to the chief priests and ancient saying,
I have sended betraying innocent blood.
But they said,
what does that to us?
Look out to it.
Yeah,
there you go.
There's the antisemitism right there.
Hey,
what do we give a shit?
Just give us a silver pieces there.
But Judy,
okay.
At casting down the pieces of silver and the temple,
he departed and went and hanged himself with a halter.
Halter top.
They had those backset but he hit himself with a,
we'll fucking sports bra.
Uh,
but the chief priests having taking the pieces of silver said it's not lawful to
put them into the core.
Boehner.
Did Chrysler used to make those?
The Chrysler Carbone orientee later.
The term might box.
What?
Duff Mike Box.
Isn't that a bug?
Also arms box or poor box refers to a box that is used to save coin or a piggy
bank.
That's what you should say to save coins for charitable purposes or for
charitable purposes.
Oh,
so then,
okay,
I get it.
So then they can say,
wait a minute,
this guy killed the king of the Jews and was sitting here with the fucking loot
from the caper.
We'll go stick it in the fucking donation box and nobody says a word.
You got me.
All right.
And then they,
after that they had consulted to get,
you know what?
This might be a new section.
You want me to guys,
I'll start reading the fucking Bible and I'll give you my interpretation of it.
Gradually I'll start my own church,
right?
And I'll say that I have a direct link to he that is the one if,
and then gradually I'll slide my direct length over and to just saying,
hey,
maybe I'm that guy,
I am that guy,
I am him a blow me.
I'm fucking all the women here.
Add A,
you guys get out in the field and grow some more apples.
It's basically fast forwarding through running a cult.
All does the FBI here,
everybody drank this
all over the lips and over the gums.
Suck it down.
Here they come.
All right.
Don't say refer to these verses known as pup up above.
Yeah,
that's really interesting and fucking said there's something sad about that,
right?
Has anybody ever had like a fucking marquis on their head site?
You know like a big grave stone and then just have like,
you don't like the Chicago theater but like to scale to a headstone
performing here for eternity
or some hacky fucking form of show business.
Ah,
Christ.
Now I gotta look this shit up.
Now I've got to look this shit up.
Okay.
Those people who have wacky headstone saying,
here we go.
Funny headstones.
Yeah.
All right,
here we go.
What do we got here?
Images for funny headstones.
Now what are the odds?
Any of these are going to be funny.
All right,
Charlie.
All these are just funny named Charlie loser,
born in ATD e seven and John Loser.
Jesus Christ is such losers.
They're buried in the same fucking place.
Jokes over.
Let me out now.
Oh,
Leslie Nielsen,
he's got a joke on his,
what does it say?
Let her rip.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
Oh,
this is just funny names stiff.
Tipman boogers.
Spanx.
Who put this up here?
Fucking beat for some Buffett,
but Adam ones by,
I'm a funny sayings.
Jesus Christ.
The Internet.
Funny.
Say Eggs.
Headstones.
Here we go.
Oh my God.
This is a riot.
Oh.
Epitaphs.
Here we go.
52,
the funniest Abta.
All right.
Somebody has.dot,
dot.
Well,
this sucks.
That's not bad.
Billy Wilder.
I'm a writer,
but then nobody's perfect.
Oh,
Jesus.
It's such an NPR joke.
Uh,
Jack Lemmon in.
Okay.
Oh,
it's like a movie headstone.
Jack Lemmon was one hell of an actor and a funny one to boot.
Here's his here.
He stars in his final role.
Well in the ground.
Ah,
that's a good one.
Uh,
this one gets to the point.
Well,
this sucks.
Okay.
It was another one.
All right.
This one.
This ain't bad.
Once you get used to it,
that's not bad.
I was supposed to live to be 102,
it'd be shot by a jealous husband.
Yeah,
near this spot.
You know something.
Actually,
if they were all interesting,
I think people would go to fucking graveyards more rather than,
than getting creeped out by it.
Uh,
near this spot.
Samuel Whitmore,
then 80 years old killed three British soldiers.
He was shot.
Bayoneted beaten and left for dead but recovered and live to be 90 years of age.
This guys talking shit.
Here.
I lie,
but don't you cry for one day two,
you will die.
Ah,
what?
I can't.
Okay.
Leslie Nielsen,
let her rip Merv Griffin.
I will not be right back after this message as a winner right there.
I liked that somebody wrote,
Ha,
get it.
Such a comedian.
You can't make anybody happy on the Internet.
All right,
Bill Kugel.
He voted for Republicans and it had little to do with them.
Yes,
that was bad.
Here's one.
Said,
I told you I was sick.
That's,
that's funny.
Yeah,
no,
the one I knew this would happen.
Somebody has a pretty good Rodney Dangerfield.
There goes the neighborhood
here lies something,
something.
Hang by mistake in 1882 he was right,
we was wrong,
but we stand him up and now he's gone.
Oh Dude,
you can't go with poetry.
Okay,
I guess that's it.
Well,
there you go guys.
That's about as good as it gets and you know,
you know you could do better.
Okay.
Once you just say,
what the fuck are you looking at it?
I don't know.
Let's,
let's read the advertising.
Shall We?
Lot of death.
A lot of debt this week.
A lot of death on the podcast.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
The readings for this week club.
Debbie Club,
Daddy,
my daddy went to Yale.
Uh,
we've been,
we've all been there.
You come home after a long exhausting,
exhausting day,
right?
You want to get shit faced and all you want us to sip.
You want to sit,
you want to sip a glass of wine and relax so you can lie to yourself to get on
an alcoholic because you're drinking wine.
But unless you plan it ahead,
you probably don't have a bottle in your house.
You've already spent enough time wandering around the grocery store.
You know,
don't get lost in the wine aisle.
You'd just end up picking out a bottle based on the label.
Yeah,
you don't really understand it.
You get home,
you open it,
you realize you don't like Chardonnay as much as you thought you didn't.
Your whole leave big stinks.
Right.
Please include all of the following points I'm going to,
you wrote it well with club,
with club Debbie.
Daddy,
can you get me into,
you have to swear to God.
I'll study.
Uh,
you never have to go about worry.
You never have to worry about a big wine free again with club.
Debbie.
Daddy,
I puked on the deed is a revolutionary new wine club that sends you wine
directly to your door,
saving you all those trips to the grocery store.
Not only does club Debbie Club,
Debbie,
I'm not really depression it,
I just hang out in the Oval Office.
Send your wine,
they send you wine that you'll love.
Drinking Club,
Debbie and club.
Debbie mom's name's Barbara.
Easy six question.
Quiz figures out your palate.
So every bottle you refreeze receive as quickly tailored to your tastes.
Clubbed Debbie Club.
Debbie is leading the grape to glass to glass wine revolution.
I can not even remotely read this week.
They worked directly with vineyards to cut out the middle man,
which saves you money club.
Debbie,
I love Debbie.
I'm going to run again.
Even offers a no risk guarantee that you'll love what they send you.
Call the action and right now it clubbed Debbie acts.
Speak Spanish is offering my listeners 50% off your first order when you go to
club Debbie at.com/bird don't ever come home to a wine free house again.
Just go to club Debbie at.com/burr to get 50% off your first order club.
Debbie and my friend shut it up.
Frame of the face with a shotgun.com/burr.
Alright,
ZipRecruiter.
Okay.
Ziprecruiter.
As a business owner,
your company is only as good as the people you hire.
Posting jobs in one place.
Well that isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Short staffing leaves little time to pose to dozens of job sites.
Well,
I have the solution with Zip,
right?
You can post to a hundred plus job sites with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes.
Plus you can watch brand new candidates roll into zip,
easy to use interface within 24 hours.
Zip
has been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Insert an improved user testimony.
Colon parentheses.
Please refer.
Please reference testimony,
you addendum,
document and parentheses offer and call to action.
I'm reading all this shit from now on today.
You can try zip recruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that's ziprecruiter.com/bar hi,
one more time.
ziprecruiter.com/bar and last.
Lastly,
but not leastly trunk club.
UAE going to the malls,
but you want to look cool.
What of a whole trunk full of fucking clothes came to your door?
Well,
it's easy.
Just go to trunk club.
Don't waste a second of the new year in a crowded mall with trunk club.
You can make 2016 your most stylish year yet.
Hey,
and the best part is you won't have to do any of the work yourself.
2016 is going to be your game changer.
You're going to be getting pussy like you never got your fresh start.
Start the year off on the right foot and the right pants.
Wearing the right jackets over the right shirt trunk club is here to handle your
wardrobe so that you can focus on what matters.
Watching ESPN.
Please include all of the following points in your read while you're wrote up.
I'm gonna read them.
Trunk Club takes the hassle man out of shopping by finding the best clothes for
you and your style.
You'll look like 1 million bucks or at least a grand.
And we'll always have the perfect close for the season@trunkclub.com slash Burr
you inc you answer simple questions about your style,
your preferences and sizes,
and it's all these signed.
Uh,
the,
all of those things are assigned to you by an expert stylist,
your stylist [inaudible] and I'm an expert.
I know what a shirt looks like.
You're,
your stylist will hand pick clothes from the best premium brands.
Just to prove the what you like and send back what you don't like it.
Just like that a trunk arrives on your doorstep filled with handpick clothes
that are perfect for you.
Handcuff pen,
pick clothes from migrant workers in the orange groves.
Um,
the shirt groves.
Try them on.
Keep what you like and easily return what you don't.
The prepaid trunk trunk club is not as subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges,
just great clothes.
Call to action.
Slash offer.
It's a brand new year full of possibilities with trunk club.
You'll start the year off looking great in clothes picked just for you.
Get started today.
How would they not know what the fuck to do at this point?
Good Lord.
This is long.
Get started today and Trunk Club will style you for free for free shipping both
ways.
You only pay for the clothes you keep.
You've already made these points to take advantage to go to trunk club.com/burr
that's trunk club.com/birth for a trunk filled the clothes you'll love wearing
in clay.
She case you didn't notice that the first 50 times I said it.
Additional points,
dimension parentheses,
not required.
Trunk Club also offers locations in La,
Chicago,
Dallas,
DC and New York City where you can meet one on one with your own personal
stylist.
Ah,
we things to do during a quarter life crisis,
a quarter life crisis.
Don't you love out advertising?
Could just come up with a fucking phobia you never had.
Who has a quarter life crisis?
Oh my God,
I'm 25.
What am I going to do?
Was the volume this far down?
Did I accidentally kicked the volume as shit?
Yeah.
Christ.
Um,
don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm still working on the garage
and uh,
I'll,
I'm going to,
I'm going to figure out how to make this fucking work.
Okay.
It's becoming,
once again,
everything in this house is a motherfucker and when I've,
I've finally learned to do is I'm not fighting the house so I'm not fighting
house anymore.
I will adapt to it.
All right?
If everything has to be some sort of a geometric shape that doesn't exist yet,
that has no definition that God dammit,
that will be the shape of the fucking room.
All right.
Is there anything else I wanted to talk about?
Um,
oh man,
this lady fucking cut me off when I was driving and just the fucking thoughts I
had and everyone that you have,
they're like,
I can't do that and go to jail.
I can't do that.
I put her eye out,
you know,
I was thinking about pulling up next to if I had a paint gun and her sticking
the wind or face out the winter to give me the finger like,
like they all do and just fucking blasting in right in the face.
And I immediately,
I was thinking about her eyes.
So that's where the paint ball went and put a rye out.
I got done and no back the fantasy up.
Okay.
Take it down a notch right in the middle of her forehead.
Hit her right in the forehead and watched the botox shootout on either side now.
But then,
you know,
people behind me would take down my plate and I just was sitting at the red
light behind her.
All of these fantasies of the Shit I wanted to do,
follow her,
find out where she fucking works slash all of her tires and then take the knife,
stick it right into the head,
rest of her driver's side seat,
you know,
with something fucking written in newspaper writing.
So you know,
when you take the fucking letters from the newspaper,
so it looks totally even more creepy.
And I was like,
well why would you do that?
There's going to be cameras in the parking lot.
You can't do that.
And then the light turned green and she made a right.
And I kept going straight and I just never thought about her again until right
now.
And with that,
that is is the a,
you guys have any yummy here.
Some,
uh,
once you write in the murderer,
his fantasies that you have when somebody cuts you off and fucking traffic,
all this shit that you think about doing but you don't do because that's the
difference between you and a psycho.
All you do is think it,
but you don't fucking,
you don't carry it out.
You know,
I at least I hope you do are also probably just got put on some sort of watch
list.
You know?
No one gives a fuck.
I'd love to be put on a watch list and I would love to be watching them.
Watch me and see how long they could watch me before they fucking nodded off.
See watching another hockey game.
Oh my God,
this is the worst assignment ever.
Jesus Christ.
Um,
all right.
That's the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Monday for,
uh,
just put Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Have a great weekend.
You can't,
let's go patriots.
I think this is going to be as always,
it's going to be a very tough game.
Going to be a very tough game.
Oh,
by the way,
I finally watched the Carolina's Seattle game and um,
this is what I have to say.
You know,
I,
I find it amazing that the Carolina Panthers,
when they had two weeks before that game even came,
right,
they had a week off,
so they had two weeks and millions of dollars at their disposal to get that
field.
Okay.
Until a better like into much better shape for that great Seattle defense.
It's amazing how they just for some reason couldn't get that together.
Now it's not illegal.
All you really have to do is just have a feel and paint some lines and put some
numbers on it.
You're not required to have it and the greatest of shape,
but that was just one of those things is a patriots fan.
You just look at it and go,
isn't that funny?
I wonder what would happen if we were to do something like that even though it's
not illegal.
That'd be a nice fucking five days.
All the patriots up to it again.
Um,
anyway,
so we're going into a Denver,
we're going into Denver.
It should be a,
a tough game.
And um,
okay.
I have a melancholy feeling about this.
Like,
this might be the last,
uh,
Brady Peyton manning match up.
You know,
and if Peyton Manning's retires after this year,
and then there's just one,
right,
Tom,
terrific.
And then some day he'll be gone.
He'll be retired and it's just,
it's going to be like Jesus fucking Christ.
I remember when they came in the fight and when those guys came in the league,
I was already in my thirties,
wasn't I?
When a patient come in 96,
I turned 30 and 98 so 30.
Yeah.
29 30 years old.
Unfucking believable and they're considered old.
Yeah,
I'll be my fifties when Tom Brady,
when tires God willing God fucking well and guidewell and he plays that long and
God willing,
I fucking make it that I would make it into my fifties and don't end up in a
fucking potter's grave.
You know,
I wouldn't give a shit.
Okay.
I think that's the most arrogant fucking thing you could possibly do is,
um,
let's give
a fuck how you're dead bodies presented for the rest of fucking time.
That's just the fucking,
it's just like,
dude,
just Frisbee Frisbee my body.
Off the back of a pickup truck down a cliff.
I don't give a shit.
Um,
oh by the way,
with the,
that just remind me of something.
The fuck was I going to say?
Ah,
Christ,
it left me.
It left me like all thoughts do.
Um,
all right,
so that's the podcast.
Have a great weekend.
Your counts.
Um,
she'll be a great game out in Denver.
I love their defense.
Um,
of course.
I don't think it's going to be an easy game and uh,
I am surprised that we have favorites because we have historically not done well
out in Denver and it always fucking smells.
All right.
I'll talk to you a to comes on Monday.
Oh No.
Why
Shit about the fucking guy things
got that.
You know,
he went over to,
he went over to Uganda,
that Guy Kony Kony 2012.
You see that?
You see how quickly they brought that guy down.
This guy shines a light on the,
uh,
on himself first and foremost,
and how he and his child or dealing with it,
which was really bizarre.
I mean,
I don't know about you guys,
but it was enough for me to see the boy soldier crying cause he saw his brother
have his next sliced right in front of them,
you know,
and he goes from that to be a,
now I'm going to sit my son down and tell him about the,
it's like a,
I didn't even get it.
All right.
So anyways,
this guy shines a light on this bullshit that's going on over there and all of a
sudden everybody's in an uproar over sin.
Everybody gives a fuck about Uganda and these boys soldiers,
you know,
and all of a sudden the United States government is gonna do it.
We're fighting two wars.
We can't even afford to fight one.
Now this guy's bringing this shit up.
Gee,
wouldn't it be nice if something fucking happened that would discredit him?
Next thing you know,
a couple of days later,
hey,
this guy connected with the film from Dec Kony 2012 gets caught jerking off in
public.
Was that the only guy who found that unbelievably fucking convenient?
I didn't buy it for a second.
In fact,
I tweeted,
you know,
back in the day,
they used to assassinate you.
Now they just do this.
You know what I mean?
If they could make it look like we landed on the moon in 1969,
you don't think that they can make you anybody they want make it look like
you're rubbing one out in the fucking parking lot.
I don't buy it.
Okay.
What that fucking Douche bag was doing,
not douche bag.
That fucking self-serving.
Cont there we go.
That's what I was trying to say.
What he was doing with that film was he was putting pressure on the United
States to go over there and fucking somehow insert themselves into that
situation,
which would it cost a ton of fucking money,
you know?
But there's no way to be like,
hey,
fuck those boys soldiers,
you know,
because of the,
of,
uh,
the way the coupe,
because of what it says in our pamphlet,
you know,
give a shit or your week,
give us your poor and will exploit the shit out of them and uh,
let them die of tuberculosis in a damp apartment.
And then years later,
whoever made the most amount of money gets a statue made out of them.
That's all in our thing.
So we can't look the other way with these fucking boy soldiers.
So what's easiest thing to do?
Just just make that guy look like a freak show.
First of all,
who hasn't jerked off in a parking lot?
Honestly?
You know who hasn't done that?
You know your rent,
you fucking girl goes in to change something.
You sitting there,
you're bored.
You can't get any radio reception cause you know it's back in the day.
He just say,
ah,
I'm bored.
Right?
He got a girl in your life.
So you know there's gonna be some sort of Napkins in the car.
What are you going to dope?
Right?
You've got the captain's chairs.
No one could see ya.
Okay.
As is taking forever.
Hey,
what am I rub one out.
All right.
Yeah,
that,
that Dah Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
But now everybody's got a fucking camera.
You know?
You know what's amazing is that everybody hasn't got caught jerking off in
public at this point.
Everybody's got a camera in there raw.
This cell phone,
when I'm trying to say people is I don't buy it and it doesn't matter.
I don't give a fuck whether the guy from Coney was jerking off in a parking lot
or not.
That doesn't change whether or not this boy soldiers in Uganda,
but what's great is,
is then the conversation switches from what's going on over there to lull let's
this Guy Dylan,
he,
he rubbing his deck like we all do
and then everybody would be like,
yeah,
but we don't do it in public.
Oh,
so what?
That makes you better.
It doesn't make you better.
It just makes you more considerate,
doesn't it?
I mean,
if he had two people and they were both shooting heroin and one person had the
decency to do it in their house and the other person does it out in public,
at the end of the day,
you both drug addicts,
so if you're really going to sit there and shit on this guy for jerking off,
then you would have to basically be not jerking off at all.
Right.
Ladies and gentlemen of the jury,
I'm asking you to look into your hearts.
If you have not rubbed one out,
let he who is not rubbed on out in some sort of pump.
Now you'd have a jerked off at work.
God,
I'm fucking bored.
Excuse me,
let me go to the bathroom.
Maybe they think I'm taking a shit standing up,
right?
Come on.
If you're a guy in your arms along enough,
at some point you've jerked off in someplace where you shouldn't have.
You jerked off to somebody you shouldn't have.
You've done it.
We've all been there.
Who gives a fuck?
There's still boys fighting and wars over this.
So you know,
if you want to help out,
help out.
If you don't,
don't,
but don't let some guy rubber one out in a parking lot.
Change your mind either way.
You know what they're doing right now that doing what women do when they argue
when they start to lose is they bring up other shit and they spin it into a
different room and next thing you know,
you're arguing a whole different argument and argument that they wanted you to
fucking argue.
So they knew that they could win rather than keeping the argument on fucking
track of saying,
listen sweetheart,
I don't like the way you fucking been dressing lately.
Okay?
I've gotten this relationship to treat you like a piece of fucking meat.
All right?
And lately you've been slacking off.
People were still boy soldiers in Uganda.
Whether or not that guys,
Robin one out are open in his ass for the world to see.
Don't ever forget that.
Don't lose sight of what the real story is.
Okay?
That is all good night and God [inaudible]
less space.
[inaudible]
all right.
Fried
chicken advice.
Hey Bill,
I'm 25 and I've been listening to your podcast for a year now and I really enjoy
it.
I wanted to get your advice on my current situation.
I could have assumed all of that.
Um,
because I'm arrogant.
Then why else would you write in?
Okay.
After a lot of failed relationships,
I wanted to try a new approach of meeting women.
I'm at a 21 year old girl through my sister in law and figured she was
interesting and pretty enough to consider for a serious girlfriend.
We started hanging out as friends so I could be sure that I was in fact able to
be friends with her before I made a move to something more seriously.
More serious,
sorry.
Things have been going well for the last two months and we get together a couple
of times a week to hang out and do stuff.
Wow.
[inaudible] last week I finally decided that I wanted to make my move on her.
I was saying goodbye to her up to hanging out,
and I finally moved in for a kiss and she backed away.
It got really awkward after that and she kind of said,
oh,
I have to go.
About 10 minutes later,
I got a text from her saying,
sorry for backing away,
but I don't want to ruin our friendship.
Ah,
okay.
Oh Dude.
You fucking waited too long.
I would go with go watch that Chris Rock special where he see does the friend
zone.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
what the hell do I do now?
She has always been very flirty with me the entire time we've been hanging out.
Oh wait.
She's been flirted with you though.
Fuck her.
She works at an all girls camp during the summer and she always hangs out with
me on her days off.
So I know there isn't anyone else she's seeing.
All right.
First of all,
scratch that.
All right.
You have no idea.
What,
what,
how does that expression go?
You know,
only the devil knows the secrets in a woman's heart.
Isn't that how it goes?
Something like that.
Did it?
Don't ever fucking you.
You have no fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
Okay.
You could have a woman in a Goddamn cell.
You still have no idea what the fuck they're doing.
Um,
the sorceress um,
anyways,
am I to believe she is so naive to think that we were just hanging out as total
platonic friends.
The only reason I could think why she would do that is because I am agnostic and
she is a semi religious girl.
What do you think I should do?
You know what you should do fucking walk Robert Deniro and heat.
Just walk away.
All right.
This is what you do.
This girl's being all flirty with you and all that type of shit.
She gets you dick hard.
You're trying to be a gentleman.
You don't try to fucking finger blast or on the first date because you think
she's special.
All right,
so three days after flying kites and going on picnics,
you go in for a kiss.
She pulls up.
Ah,
eh.
They didn't want to ruin the friendship.
Give me a fucking break.
She knows what the fuck she's doing.
All right.
She's toy in with you since this is what you do.
This is the best thing that you can do.
When a woman does something like that that makes you want to go out and eat
fucking sheet metal is you don't,
you don't give them the emotion that they want,
which is she.
They want you to be upset.
And uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I don't why I have no,
I don't know fucking why,
but she wants you to be upset.
So this is what you do.
Okay.
You just say,
Oh yeah,
hey,
I didn't know what I was doing.
That's cool.
Whatever.
All right.
And then she had very few,
any friends,
it'd be like,
yeah,
absolutely.
We can totally be friends.
Okay.
All right.
So I don't try to fucking bang or anymore,
don't blow her off.
So she has no idea what you're doing.
Just keep hanging out with their whatever,
doing this and that.
And then what you do just start fucking working out.
You get jacked,
right?
And then on the side you talking to other broads and then one day you show up
with a fucking Goddamn Hickey on the side of your neck,
you know,
and then you fucking just don't even address it.
What's said,
hey,
you know what I'm saying?
And it was some girl last night.
So what are you doing today?
And you just,
you just,
you mind fucker right back.
You fight fire with fire.
That's what you do get on with your life,
sir.
Fuck her.
That's it.
All right.
That's,
that's what I feel
my solution is always the same.
Okay.
Is when whenever a girl does some shit like that.
All right.
Or if a girl breaks up with you or anything like that and,
and uh,
if a girl still wants to be friends with you after she broke up with you,
don't,
all right.
You get the fuck away from her hurt locker.
Okay.
Put on your bomb suit and fucking walk away.
Don't be,
don't be the hero you fucking walk away because they just want to keep you in
their life as they slowly get over you and just constantly be taking a steak
knife and shoving it into your heart.
Fuck that.
All right.
You get away from him.
This,
there's no point being around this girl.
So right now this girl just tried to mind fuck you.
So if you automatically just cut off being around her,
she's going to win on some level and she'll actually get some sort of level of
satisfaction that you reacted that way.
Cause.
Because even though you think you're saying,
fuck you,
what you're really saying is I actually cared about you and that's going to feed
her God.
Damn Ego said don't do that.
So just be like,
yeah,
I don't know what I was thinking.
You know?
Uh,
yeah,
you can't.
Yeah,
You can't blame a guy for triad that'll annoy her.
Like she's just some piece of meat you took a swing at.
This is such terrible fucking advice,
but you know what?
I believe in it.
This is how I've lived my life.
If you want to end up like me,
43 not married,
no kids,
that's how you do it.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Just whatever she wants to hang on.
Hey,
let's hang out and don't be weird around her.
Okay?
Don't be with,
hey,
sorry about that.
I Dunno,
I was an idiot or whatever.
Now that's what you do.
That's what you do.
All right.
And then what you do is start talking about some other girl.
Wait a couple of weeks and just say,
hey,
you know,
I kind of met this girl.
I kind of liked her and blah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
this is,
this is a fucking,
this is the old hook and lateral play.
I don't know if this'll work.
This is definitely a hail Mary.
But maybe if you fucking start saying,
hey,
and I met this girl and I kind of fucking like,
are you show up at the Hickey on her neck?
I don't know what happens.
There's spinal cord muscles,
the spinal cord muscles,
the muscles around the spinal cord get fucking eye.
They get weak.
Yeah.
And I,
and all of a sudden they just fall face first of the elap.
Sometimes that happens,
you know,
but you're not going to know unless you try it.
All right?
Don't be Chris Webber and be looking to pass the fucking ball here.
If you want to take the shot,
you understand me?
So what you do,
sometimes I say this shit and I,
and I've stepped outside of myself and I just realized what a fucking moron I
sound like.
But I don't know if some reason you guys listen to this shit,
so whatever.
Good luck to you.
I just tapped.
Oh,
those time.
Yay.
You
can do some little differences this week
rather than me just sitting here in my pajamas ranting,
ranting and raving.
I decided that I would get closed this week and have a friend of mine come by.
Um,
the one and only dom,
I rera everybody.
Thank you.
Everybody at,
do you mind if I get undressed?
Huh?
No,
I would feel more comfortable.
I like in the nude and food in the nude,
not in the nude.
I realize now,
you know,
look,
look how much weight I've gained right now.
You know,
I've gained since I've known you 30 pounds.
Right.
And I know that.
I can't tell.
Well,
you don't really look,
you don't really check me out.
What it is all done at my head.
My head is bigger.
What you wearing?
That slimming black tee shirt?
I've got to Barry bonds head,
but it's,
it's interesting because now I don't even know if this is a bit yet,
Bill,
but I think there's something in it.
I have to look.
I don't like women my own age.
Right.
And I mean,
I can't,
I can't fake that I get aroused by them.
I always wondered that.
No,
I always wanted to glean.
I wish I had that kind of love or something,
but I need like a hot young chick,
but the only hot young chick I'm going to get has to be flawed.
Right.
Does she gotta be as daddy issue inside or outside?
Yeah.
Just gotta be messed up in some way.
But that's what I'm looking for.
How many,
uh,
how many strippers have you,
have you dated,
dated?
Uh,
only a couple.
I was in love with one.
How old?
How old were you when you did,
when you made that move?
Uh,
two years ago.
He fell in love with the stress level was just,
first of all,
it's just a country song.
She was,
um,
she was not stripping at the time.
She was bartending and just given the occasional lap dance
and really beautiful girl.
I've been to that bar.
I had fun,
but I'll tell you,
oxycontin and alcohol really mess you up.
I don't know if you knew that.
Yeah,
I got some.
Uh,
but I still loved the girl,
but she's a,
I don't think,
I don't think we're getting back together cause that oxy,
her husband and her two kids keep blocking us.
Oh Jesus.
Dom,
you're making me feel good.
Make me feel good.
Some of the choices I made back in the day,
dude,
oxy is uh,
that's a terrible right.
Yeah.
That's one
of those things like even when you get off at your,
I don't know that you're ever,
uh,
depending on how long you do it,
the same.
I lost a buddy of mine did that.
Oh really?
I got another one.
He's not doing so well.
Did you grow up in a neighborhood that was a lot of drugs?
I'm not like that.
Not like that.
It was a,
I grew up,
you know,
it was,
it was called the sac bullshit.
It was weed.
There was the weed guy,
there was the bookie and then w and then there was,
you know,
blues obviously,
but you know,
in some coke when you got older,
but uh,
like nobody was doing like heroin and crack was like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Cause everybody thought if you smoke crack,
that was it.
You had done well the,
they say you get addicted the first time they said,
but I got friends of mine who did and they're like,
oh really?
Yeah.
Maybe they were addicted to other things they didn't have time to be.
Maybe they're just better people and better,
stronger.
You have good friends.
Let me ask you this.
If you had one drug that you think you would like,
what would it be?
I know what mine is.
If you,
if I could do a drug that I've never tried tried and you think that like it's
not going to have any repercussions.
Just want to the feeling.
What feeling would it be?
Not telling you I have a tie.
He's,
I want to know.
I want to know what it feels like.
Like that train spotting where you sink into the rug the first time you do
heroin.
That's exactly,
that's exactly what I want that,
but I got to admit the hallucinating thing tripping,
but I'll put that,
somebody told me,
like you said,
like when you're tripping,
it's not like you don't know the a trepan you see the door fucking melting.
You're like,
oh,
it's because I'm on acid.
It's not like those high school films where you'd be like,
you thought you could fly and shit like that,
jump out the window.
No,
I,
I uh,
what was that movie with that old guy?
Was it something to me?
Larry Alan Arkin did a part where he played an old guy and he fucking,
uh,
he just,
he got addicted to heroin like his seventies.
He's just like,
what the fuck?
I'm 70.
That's a guy.
I said,
good idea just to try it.
It's 70.
I mean,
I'd rather go out shooting drugs and go out taking,
you know,
kick in the ass.
That was hurt,
man.
That's the thing.
You ever think about that seriously?
Bill was taken one?
Yeah,
excepting one.
I think it's taking one for the team and taking one for the team.
I tell him your number came up side and I'm going like this like this.
I don't think so.
I could,
we work this out now.
I've actually thought he was only a priest.
How I,
how I want to go out in by wolves eat shredded by animals.
Yeah.
I either want to live to be like a 105 like you lived so long that this like
nobody at your funeral because you outlived everyone who gives a shit or the,
you know,
cause that,
that is a funny image cause that's one of the things if you live long enough,
I'd be worried had people that cared about people doing the eulogy.
Like I mean,
you know,
he says I met him when he was 87 and uh,
he was all like,
he like playing cards.
Those slippers always wore those slippers.
But if you die like,
you know,
like all my friends,
you know who have died tragically fucking young,
its seams.
You pack the house and everybody's up there flying.
That's the only good thing about dying young is everybody gives a fuck.
There's articles written about you there.
There's nothing worse when,
I mean there's nothing worse than dying yet,
but Diane old also is,
you know,
you sit in there that you got that fucking all terrified picture.
Yeah.
My uncle Tony,
when he died,
he really was very prejudiced and very angry,
but he also loved his children.
He loved God.
He loved the mountains.
And then when he died was so funny that makeup for the racist.
Yeah,
but I'm saying he was that balanced prices on people in the nature love bird.
It's true though.
He was like all that.
And he's,
and we're standing around the coffin.
You see that mountain?
It's for us.
Not these other people.
This is God's country.
But we're,
when we're around the corner from,
we're standing,
you know,
people lie about people after they died.
And this guy leaves for Deli,
who was the first a tank character ever did.
Like I got down a little,
uh,
he said,
we're staying there.
Me and a friend of mine who was a priest and like a couple of my cousins and
we're standing there over the body and he goes,
he never had a bad word to say about anybody.
And we went from crying to fucking lab for,
and I'm thinking,
I said,
all we do is have bare word said,
but everybody,
and then he goes,
listen to this,
this is a really old reference.
He goes,
he never hated anybody except Larry Bowa,
right?
Larry Bobo,
the old for the Phillies.
And he goes,
and he looks up,
he goes,
he hated that motherfucker would have vengeance.
Was he a gambler?
No,
he didn't gamble.
He just hated them.
He hated the Larry Bode cause he hit one 75 but he was a great fielder.
But I mean,
Halloween.
What,
what an obscure reference to make it a funeral.
Excellent general.
Back in the day,
he probably just didn't like second basement,
maybe got to Florida,
but I love that everybody laughed.
I've had a couple of those.
It like funerals were crying,
crying,
the crying,
laughing.
I did that one time.
A Buddy of mine,
his dad died and it was just one of those fucking,
you know,
tragic.
You know,
we were young and he died on a nowhere and the kid had already lost,
his mom was fucking horrible.
And uh,
so it was pouring,
raining to make it even worse.
Fucking like the,
remember the movie seven?
It was raining like that.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we,
we,
you know,
go,
we'll go through the surface and now they're gonna,
you know,
put the guy in the ground and the guy was so popular.
I mean,
there was just a zillion people there,
so they had like one of these,
you know,
one of those pop tents with no sides to it.
So there's so many fucking people,
everybody's jamming in there.
Me and my buddy can't get in,
you know,
we're on the outer ring,
we're just getting rained on and shit.
And my other asshole friend is just inside the tent and he's sitting there and
we're all crying and stuff and it bringing the body down and all of a sudden
just from the weight of the rain,
like this little like canals started pouring down in just missing my friend and
my buddy in the middle of crimes are standing range,
just reached up and adjusted it so
it went all over his ego.
But he had like this wool kind of coat on so he couldn't feel it at first.
And Dude,
I'm talking,
crying,
laughing,
just crying because it was so sad and that this is take two that I never thought
people ever understanding about comics when they have a distasteful joke like of
a boat sinks as a plane crash and you have a joke.
Yeah,
they always think it's cause you're insensitive and they sometimes don't
understand that it's,
it's a defense mechanism which getting the pain.
Yeah,
I'm feeling something bad.
I don't want to feel it.
And then you,
you,
you make a fucking joke and then you're laughing because you don't want to feel
that.
So you actually doing it because you can,
it's kind of a,
I've,
I think,
uh,
it's a dysfunction.
It's kind of a form of dysfunction.
Well,
like the pedophile jokes,
we all know how terrible that is and yet
you can twist them around.
I usually bring it up
back on myself.
You know,
like a one joke that says,
you know what about me,
father,
I wasn't hot enough for you.
You know what I mean?
Like that kind of thing to make it me.
I wouldn't want to hurt a kid,
but there's a good example of something that's because so many people,
so much pain,
and I'm not just talking about the physical pain,
but um,
you know,
we do.
I,
no,
you're,
you end somebody's life when you,
that's why that,
that said Dusky guy.
Yeah.
You know,
like they shouldn't put those good date.
They should automatically get the death penalty just immediately.
Yeah.
It's all the take 'em out,
dude.
If you've got a rabid dog in your neighborhood,
you fucking put it down.
Those sex offender guys,
that's it.
Because all those people that that dude fucked with.
Yeah.
It's like that's going to now affect,
you want to talk about dating strippers?
Like how that's going to affect who they pick.
You know who they pick as a,
uh,
a wife,
how they treat their kids.
They might think they,
there's a chance that they could,
you know,
sometimes,
I don't know if it had happened,
I'm going to go beyond my intelligence on this shit.
What does isn't too hard to do,
but I,
all I know is that that's generations of therapy because of the abuse of th they
repeat the,
the whoever,
they don't get the free,
you can't put that guy in jail.
And like,
I mean,
how long like you're attracted to what you're attracted to no matter in a cell.
Well,
especially dom,
if they stuck you in a cell,
how long before you wouldn't like big titted strippers,
you'd come out 80 years later.
I'm dumb.
I,
I wait,
get,
bring me to some big ticket stripper.
Those guys,
like eight year olds,
you stick them in a cell and you talk to him.
You try to undo it and show him an adult that they're wired that way.
That's it.
Fucking sick.
Is that put up the ad.
It's,
it's terrific.
It's why I don't believe in a higher power that gives a fuck.
Yeah.
Well,
that's a whole different subject,
but I understand that.
But did you hear that pedophile joke about,
uh,
he might have a tell joke joke.
No,
not at all.
It's a two guys sitting on a bench and see an 11 year old boy walked by
pedophile.
It says it.
The other one goes,
boy,
he must've been hot back in the day.
He must've been sub the back in the day.
Oh,
that's fucking twisted.
Yeah.
[inaudible].